at Google i/o 2017 we announced the life
cycle library a set of libraries and
guidance for avoiding memory leaks and
solving common Android lifecycle
challenges the life cycle library has
hid 2.0 it's also now part of jetpack
and includes new integrations with data
binding this is a tour of the lifecycle
libraries live data class live data is
an observable data holder class that is
also lifecycle aware let's take a look
at example you're gonna have your UI and
then you're also gonna have this live
data object which holds some data that
you want to show on screen the UI
observes the live data object this is
like saying the UI wants to be notified
of updates therefore when the live data
changes the UI will get notified and
then the UI can redraw itself with the
new data
so in short live data makes it easy to
keep what's going on screen and synch
with the data ok so here's some actual
code live data objects will usually be
kept in the view model class if you're
not sure what a view bubble is no
worries check out the video let's say
you're creating an activity and view
model for a user profile you'll have
this user live data object that holds a
user object now over in your activities
on create you'll get that live data from
the view model class call observe on the
live data for the first argument you're
gonna pass in the UI in this case the
activity the second argument is a
observer which is just a callback here
you will call the code to update the UI
now you can change the live data by
calling either set value or post value
use set value if you're running on the
UI thread and then use post value if
you're running on a background thread
when either set value or post value is
called the live data notifies active
observers if you're using Android studio
3.1 or higher live data and view models
work with data binding usually you're
going to go ahead and bind your view
model to your XML layout which is
explained in the view model video now
after associating your view model and
data binding layout you just need to add
the single line change to have your live
data be properly observed when bound to
the XML you can now include references
in your XML to your view model and the
live data stored within it if you use
data binding you're going to no longer
need to actually Mamie Li set up these
observers so instead of creating the
live data observer code that I showed
you before you could remove all that
boilerplate instead the text views xml
references that live data directly what
makes live down to different from other
observables is that it is also lifecycle
aware this means that it understands
whether your UI is on screen off screen
or destroyed live data knows about your
UI state because you pass it in when you
call observe okay so here are some
benefits of live datas lifecycle
awareness so let's say your activity is
not on screen then your live data
doesn't trigger useless UI updates if
the activity or UI gets destroyed that
the observation connection is cleaned up
automatically by live data thus you'll
never accidentally trigger an activity
or fragment that is off screen or
destroyed to redraw itself this is
possible in part because of interfaces
and classes in the lifecycle library
that are also used by framework classes
these classes are life cycle which is an
object that represents an android
lifecycle and what state it's in
lifecycle owner which is an interface
for objects that have a lifecycle like
app compat activity or an activity
fragment and finally lifecycle observer
which is an interface for observing a
lifecycle okay so live data is a
lifecycle observer it abstract away the
need for you to deal directly with
activity or fragment lifecycle so those
are the basics of working with live data
and why it's useful I'm going to touch
on a few more complex usages room is
built to work well with live data room
can return live data objects which are
automatically notified when the data
base data changes and have their data
loaded in a background thread this makes
it easy to have the UI update when your
database updates you can go ahead and
learn more about room in the
introduction to room video live data
also provides transformations including
map switch map and a class called
mediator live data for your own custom
transformations map lets you apply a
function to the output of live data a
and then propagate the results down
straight to live data B for example you
can use live data to take a user object
and instead output a string of the users
combined first and last name the switch
map function transformation is a lot
like map but for mapping functions that
emit live data instead of values so an
example here is if you have a bunch of
users perhaps stored in a room
you might have a lookup function for
those users using switch map you'd have
a live data for the user ID
whenever the ID changes your user lookup
function would be called with that ID
the results live data now reference is
the newly found user live data okay so
no matter how many different times you
call this lookup function again a
different live data your UI only needs
to observe the result live data at once
which is the power of switch map now if
you want to go ahead and make your own
custom data transformations you should
take a look at the mediator live data
class mediator live data includes
methods to add and remove source live
data objects you can then combine and
propagate events from all of these
sources downstream getting started with
live data is simple but there is a lot
of potential for experimentation with
this life cycle where observable
hopefully this is inspired you to build
something and as always the
documentation is linked